If you want to hear all three of my theories
about Hospice, then stick around to the end
of this video.
Sponsored by Crypt TV.
Crypt TV has just brought back Hospice, the
hospital ghost story that originally haunted
doctors and patients in late 2017.
So before we explore the Things You Missed
in the latest episode, let’s revisit what
happened back in episode one.
Sharon is a nurse taking care of a patient
named Mr. Nowak, who suddenly sits up and
starts suffocating.
Next thing we know, his corpse is being taken
away, and Sharon is pretty shaken up by the
incident.
The doctor gives her the option to leave,
but she decides to still work her night shift.
As the body is taken away, a marble falls
off the stretcher, and Sharon holds onto it.
Later that night, one of her co-workers, Jake,
asks Sharon to cover for him as he takes off
30 minutes early, leaving Sharon alone in
the hospice wing.
Shortly after, the lights start flickering
before Sharon is attacked by the ghost of
Mr. Nowak, who cannot be seen on the security
camera footage.
When the doctor eventually finds her body,
he doesn’t seem as shocked as he should
be.
“Not again.”
So episode 2 starts with a new nurse named
Alice Carroll.
She’s having some kind of vision of a kid
being attacked by a monster -- we can tell
from the symbol on it’s head and the fangs,
that this is Brute, from the Crypt Monster
Universe episode The Door In The Woods which
is about four kids who accidentally unleash
this monster upon their colony.
Alice is pulled out of her vision by the sound
of flatlining.
She reports on the time of death 11:05.
This doesn’t match up with the time we just
saw on the EKG machine, which could either
mean that this is still part of the vision
of the kid being mauled by Brute, or this
is just a small continuity error, because
the date also doesn’t match the date put
on the patient’s morgue tag either.
The doctor notices she is distressed and tells
her, “you’ll get used to them… the dead.”
At first, he seems to be referring to her
getting used to patients dying, but on closer
inspection, he could also be referring to
the ghosts seen in the hospice ward.
Alice offers to wheel the patient down to
the morgue, so her fellow nurse Barbara Hasley
gives her the instructions to take a right
at the end of the basement corridor, emphasizing
to ONLY go right.
Alice’s curiosity leads her to go left anyway
after seeing the sign that it leads to hospice
wing, but she gets caught pretty quickly.
“That wing is closed.”
It is?
Then why is the door open with the lights
on?
Is there some presence trying to beckon Alice
into this forbidden territory?
When Alice gets into the morgue, she startles
the metalhead coroner, who’s cleaning up
blood at the time of her arrival.
Alice notices a mortuary cabinet labeled with
the name Kane and asks if this is Dr. Kane’s
son, probably the same Dr. Kane who owns this
hospital.
Dan tells her that the kid died of heart disease,
which doesn’t match up with the visions
or the fact that he’s cleaning up blood
off the table when she arrives, though the
blood theoretically could have been from one
of the others.
Alice goes to investigate more about Norman
Kane, but before she gets the chance, Barbara
shows up and warns her again to stay out of
the hospice wing.
Back in the morgue, Kane’s cabinet bursts
open and this monster emerges and throws Dan
into a transformer box, causing lights to
flicker around the hospital.
I like how there’s actually a practical
reason for the lights flickering, and it’s
not just explained away by the hospital being
haunted.
This also ties back into the flickering lights
from the first episode and that leads me to
my first theory: episode 1 takes place after
the rest of this season.
This can be supported by the flickering lights
that were never fully fixed after episode
2, and the fact that the doctor says, “not
again” after discovering Sharon’s body
in the first one.
The date on the security footage from the
first episode is November 10th, just 8 days
after the death of Mr. Conley in the first
episode.
My second theory is that Alice has psychic
abilities.
Upon arriving at the hospital for her first
day, she’s able to see a vision of Kane’s
son being killed, and she’s even seen rubbing
her head as if focusing some kind of psychic
energy.
When she goes down to the basement corridor,
she takes the left into the hospice wing,
despite just being told to go right.
I feel like something from beyond lured her
to go explore in that direction.
She also seems pretty quick to believe in
the supernatural when her and Barbara discuss
it.
“Do yourself a favor.
Forget what you heard.”
“Why?
Are the stories real?”
Then towards the end of the episode she goes
back to explore the area again, and it looks
as if she sees something at the end of the
hall, but when we cut to the reverse, there’s
nothing there.
The second theory leads into my third and
final theory: Alice’s co-worker Barbara
is one of the ghosts, trying to lure Alice
in.
If Alice is a psychic, she’d be the only
one who sees Barbara.
There’s no interaction between Dr. Evans
and Barbara in the opening scene...
“Five years I’m here and he hasn’t looked
at me once.”
Barbara also gives oddly specific directions
for Alice to only turn right at the end of
the basement corridor, it’s almost as if
she wants to pique Alice’s curiosity and
lure her into the haunted wing.
The other scene with Barbara is again just
the two of them, and again, Barbara doesn’t
provide specific details about why Alice should
keep out of the hospice wing.
If you have any theories about Hospice and
how it ties into the other Crypt series, be
sure to let me know in the comments.
And if you haven’t already, make sure you’re
subscribed to Crypt TV for new scary videos
every Monday, Wednesday and Friday.
Every Friday they upload a new chapter to
the Crypt Monster Universe, so click the link
in the description so that you don’t miss
out on any future installments -- and as always,
I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming, we both survive.